i want to talk about denver because we
just went to denver and like dove into
i'm gonna call it crypto mania um which
i think is a fun perspective i don't
want to dive into web3 a lot of folks
are not necessarily like into crypto or
that sort of thing per se
um but this was a wild experience uh how
was your your time in denver andrew what
did you learn about
i had a blast it reminded me of a lot of
tech conferences i've been to but
turned up a bit higher yeah they threw
you on main stage last minute which was
really fun oh i saw a lot of people i
knew yeah uh
a lot of the yang gang former yang gang
current yang gang waver was have gone
into
web 3 which has been fun
yeah so i had a blast i enjoyed it
immensely met a lot of tremendous
entrepreneurs a lot of young people
there's a lot of energy and youth
so it makes you
optimistic about the future of the space
because if you have that much ingenuity
and energy then some good things are
going to develop for those who maybe
missed last week's episode um last
thursday's episode we started something
called lobby three and the idea is to
get the community of folks interested in
crypto entities and web3 together to
advocate and lobby in dc for
what web3 can do specifically around
eradicating poverty now
you tweeted about this we had a whole
we're pushing it and we're maybe pushing
the next couple weeks we want to build
this up
political twitter did not understand
this and i wanted to address something
because some of our audience is part of
that world you you said and i agree with
this thing is that web3 can or has the
best potential of any tool we have
to eradicate poverty it can't eradicate
poverty and
man blue check twitter's like that
doesn't make any sense you know nothing
right so i wanted to ask you in your
eyes how
what do you mean when you say it can
eradicate poverty how would that work
what ideas are you looking at what
excites you about that you have a space
in an industry that now
has a market cap collectively of
uh over two trillion dollars
that did not exist seven years ago right
and i've met now
hundreds of people who've had their
lives transformed economically including
a lot of creators who were producing
things and
were having a hard time accessing the
market because the media market and the
art market in particular very very
narrow and institutionalized
but through
nfts they've been able to command
incomes that they never could have
imagined you can have mechanics where a
creator gets paid for a resale in a way
that was never possible before you start
talking to these folks and you realize
wait a minute like you know some of you
have the equivalent of a universal basic
income some of you have the equivalent
of these kind of social economies that
i
was writing about back in 2017 2018 that
have come alive this is to me one of the
most profound opportunities maybe the
most profound opportunity to fight
poverty uh that's on the table right now
i mean what are the other major
opportunities to fight poverty uh lobby
congress for the enhanced child tax
credit which we're doing but one of the
cases we're making right now is that dc
is kind of broken and dysfunctional
that's your situation like you still try
and push push push you know and then you
try to reform the system
but you also look around and say wait
like that there are whole new economies
that are emerging that are being enabled
by digital currencies and other
innovations
so let's try and make the most of that
and if you have a space that's
worth trillions of dollars one of my
personal ambitions by coming in and
saying look we have to demonstrate that
this can be used to benefit the broader
public then maybe it's perceived to or
maybe that it is right now let's take
a billion and fight some poverty with it
and then show people what can be done i
mean a billion would be a very small
fraction of what's happening in web 3.
so i'm pumped about it so i mean an
example is if you
record a song and it's an nft now
any time it's played you could get the
pennies yourself instead of funneling it
through spotify or the record labels
which you're talking about giving money
to the masses instead of the few right
instead of the institutional company
yeah web3
could be the middleman killer yeah and
right now the middlemen are the biggest
companies in the history of the world
yeah sort of for in some of the cases
you know what i mean and many yeah in a
number of cases so we're going to do an
ama on friday the 25th is tomorrow if
you're listening to this
when it comes out on thursday um
with scott saints who's been on this
podcast before but he's working on a
number of projects that
are
versions of ubi and the blockchain but
what like okay zach it's tough to get on
the blockchain how do we do that but
here's what's exciting i'm excited about
and you kind of i want to pick your
brand on this too because you kind of
talked about this when you ran for mayor
um and it was in your book war on normal
people about digital social credits
which i was like this doesn't make any
sense or this is too crazy um but
the concept is
if you took a neighborhood
that needed an economic lift
and
you said hey here is a
you know
hartford let's say harper county came
from hartford coin
and if you spend it in hartford it's
worth 10 times you know you can return
it back for 10 cents on the dollar so
you get 10x of what you ever pay for
what we give you right in terms of
dollars but if you spend it in hartford
in these businesses or restaurants or
whatever local stuff it's worth
exactly it's worth you know 10 times
more than a dollar right and you can get
it back and you can create economic
value
for more than what you've paid for and
you can do that on the blockchain
because other folks that live in
hartford with therefore wanted their
supply and demand you can control it
without having to do all the formal
currency
problems we have in terms of creating
new currencies within the united states
or globally um
talk more about that or how it would
work or if that excites you too
hopefully scott will talk about it too
on our discord in friday oh yeah i'm
super excited about it because one of
the primary
things you can do
with the blockchain is have what's
called smart money
where it changes properties based upon
the type of place you spend it
right yeah like it it like you know that
there's total transparency attached to
it so it's not uh you know it's not not
as prone to corruption and the rest of
it
if you wanted to try and rejuvenate
neighborhoods
uh some of them have already adopted
local currencies uh with some positive
results uh ithaca i believe had its own
currency
uh there are different towns that have
done this
in my view in an ideal world eventually
you reach a point where you it's plug
and play where you can have a local
currency
some of the things that i'm most
concerned about um right now you have
this winner take all economy the values
flowing all up into the cloud to amazon
you're going to decimate downtowns and
small businesses
yeah already right and that now if you
live in a particular town you know what
you get told a lot buy local and you're
like okay let me do that walk around
brooklyn they'll say buy local yeah and
then that that works on you every once
in a while but then generally speaking
you just take the path of least
resistance yeah uh so what the heck does
the future look like and then the future
looks like frankly more and more winner
take all the comme uh economics unless
you had a way to genuinely
uh reward and reinforce and incentivize
these behaviors that we talk about
but we don't actually reward you for
doing correct you have no incentive
right now unless you're either super
rich
or so
you have to be super rich i think to
start your own boutique fashion store in
brooklyn right now there's not
there's no you're not gonna have the
foot flow the foot traffic you're not
gonna have you're gonna have all the
expenses and then you'll be competing
with
global conglomerates and people that can
just buy it while sitting on their couch
at home right
so if you added economic extensive to
folks like hey yeah you can buy on
amazon right but if you buy here locally
it's you get 10 times the value and then
like then or if you volunteer at the
local nonprofit and you get this
currency that you can then use and like
the local shops downtown and then like
you actually can start to build yep like
a more robust
uh local economy
in whole new imaginative ways
managed locally instead of the federal
government being like this is what's
valuable it's like the people of
brooklyn whatever city you're this is
one of the frustrations i have about our
system man it's like
you know it's like all of the economic
flows head in a particular direction
let's say to amazon just to keep things
simple in a way everyone can understand
and then you'll have a bunch of folks
you know essentially like paying lip
service to the other thing
um it's not going to work
and we we talk about it just to make
ourselves feel better
so you know you just have to look at the
the actual
economic system it'll lead you to a
predictable outcome now the great thing
is that you can build whole new local
economic systems i mean this could
become like a
you know uh like a non-profit executives
or museum
executive or
city planner or
like local officials dream dream come
true you redo cities yeah faster than
you ever could have before yeah the
frustration i have is like essentially
the people who are put in that position
and you and i know this is people who
ran nonprofits it's like they're they're
like standing on top of a sinking ship
but all their economic incentives are
just to like talk about oh we can like
you know if we all come together we'll
be able to like create the whole thing
even though
you know and hey i'm not getting paid
enough and like all i do is sing for my
supper so that my organization can stay
afloat until i'm out and the world's
going to disintegrate around me while
i'm like like i mean that's an email
what are they solving nothing right like
they talk um yeah so so what you need
systems is like is different economic
systems uh that can be adopted a
localized level and
the blockchain and web3 are potentially
a very powerful way to do that yes
what we're trying to do is that this is
it's new it's exciting but it needs is
the wild west right now it does need
like sensible regulation and oversight
because
if done wrong there's scams there's done
wrong like you don't want to hurt the
people already vulnerable right with bad
systems that are ineffectively managed
but you also want to empower the right
people to set them up so
um that is the point of lobby three to
figure out ideas like this that can get
people banked for the first time give
them economic incentives locally redo
our broken system
and we need the federal government
and our state governments to really um
understand this be educated on this know
what to advocate for we need the left in
my opinion to be championing the human
side of this right now they're like
krypton
and that's that's destructive to me well
the left in theory
is for
uh broader distribution everything yeah
it's for transparency uh it's for
uh trying to
dislodge some of the mega corpse
and
uh web 3 could be a path to these things
it's just that most folks on the left
have something of a skepticism or
mistrust of
uh
technology and innovation at this point
unfortunately which is something that
you know i'd love to help change and i
get that we're trying to change it
that's what lobby three's doing so if
you wanna check it out we're gonna be
with scott um tomorrow in our discord
you can find the discord it's it's on
lobby three dot io or um on andrew's
twitter profile you can just click the
link click the link um that'll be in the
afternoon you know it should be up for a
while too so um
anyway super exciting we start minting
we start building this community
on monday upcoming which is
crazy uh we have over
i mean by the time you got this we're
gonna be close to four or five thousand
people in the discord uh and growing
which is super exciting we've got this
whole new if you're into web three join
us if you're not into web three maybe
maybe check it out
or you can ignore it don't worry about
it yeah it's uh
yeah as long as your friends in crypto
know about it you should be okay there's
enough voices there that are excited
about this that we can get behind yeah
hopefully we'll make it obvious a little
bit later
that's true that's one of the things
[Music]
you